Hello, my name is Hoi.
And welcome to This Week in
Android Development on Tuesday,
December the 3rd, 2013.
My American colleagues
are taking a week off,
giving thanks, eating turkey,
and watching football.
In this week's Android
Design in Action,
the usual team and some
very special guests
speak about their
favorite design flourishes
in Android apps.
And just in time to get you
all ready for Christmas,
Stephanie Alexander's
expertise is now
available via the Cook's
Companion Android app.
There has been an interesting
development with Chrome
and ADB called ChromeADB.
When launched, you can
see all devices connected
to the machine, install
APK and running processes.
You can easily
clear the cache data
or uninstall a specific app.
You can even monitor
real-time heap status
of a specific process, and
this is an open source project.
The first episode of UXD
airs Tuesday with Nazmul,
and the very special
guest, Izabel.
And that's it, This Week
in Android Development.
Be sure to check out
this week's show.
I'm Hoi Lam, dashing
through the snow
in a one-horse open sleigh.